[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
a special edition of quad Riga coming to
you from the heart of Berlin and Germany
it's today facing an unprecedented
crisis after talks on forming a new
coalition government following
September's election broke down it was
one of the smaller parties in the
four-way negotiations missed the
business-friendly free Democrats under
their leader Christie and Lintner that
pulled out saying there was no shared
vision and not enough trust to form a
new government it all leaves Chancellor
Angela Merkel's future hanging in the
balance
she was aiming to begin a fourth term in
office now though all the talk is of
possible fresh elections and in the
meantime a long period of damaging
uncertainty for Germany and Europe so
our question here on our quadriga
special show is coalition talks collapse
disaster for Germany and to discuss that
question I'm joined here in the studio
by three excellent guests beginning with
fairness honor journalist and author and
one of the outstanding commentators on
German politics in over four decades of
also with this is Alain Posner welcome
back Ellen he's a commentator for
devotes newspaper and a very warm
welcome to to arica Hermann from another
berlin-based daily the taps or targets
item thank you on this auspicious or
inauspicious day I'm not quite sure of
Arizona Berlin is in a state of shock
according to one newspaper headline this
morning do you share that assessment yes
and no certainly the political the
political class is in a shock situation
but Germany is not in a crisis Germany
as such is doing very well economically
not politically at the moment but
overall Germany is not in a crisis
situation we are facing a domestic
political crisis for sure one that we
have not had in our history and the word
the buzzword right now is uncertainty
you were nodding immediately as fairness
said we're not in a crisis
no sir no sign of crisis on their
writing at all well no because I'm gonna
market our Chancellor is still in charge
and whatever will happen she will
that's my prognosis remain the
Chancellor it's only the question how to
rule Germany whether we have this
experiment of minority government which
which would be new for Germany but I
think it would work
or whether we have new elections but
then again I think maca will gain in
votes and will be stronger than before
so I'm just agree that we are not in a
crisis most German commentators this
past week have been asked the question
will will the talks be broken off at any
stage leading to fresh elections or
whatever the next scenario is going to
be we're gonna have to talk about that
they've all said no no it's not going to
happen and then you guys are sitting
here and saying it's the most normal
thing in the world we didn't say that
but you know just as you said in in this
film at the beginning the problem were
the Liberals they are a very small party
and indeed they are not fit to rule
because I didn't have enough people who
were fit for government they didn't have
a program that would have worked and
they didn't have enough technical
knowledge in order to be part of the
government so what we don't have a
general crisis what we have is a Liberal
Party that's not fit to rule okay
another opportunity very shortly to talk
the Liberals down where are we today
well I want to come back to what you
said about we're sitting here saying
owners what crisis there is of course a
crisis of the chattering class I think
this is the third time we've been wrong
you were wrong about brexit everyone was
like never going to happen
we're wrong about Trump never gonna
happen and I personally was wrong about
because I'm on record saying of course
Jamaica's gonna happen it's just a
question of finding the right compromise
formula and and and the question is
really why did the Liberals pull out and
it's not one second yeah for you go on
to why the Liberals pulled out just
explain for our viewers the use of the
word we cuz we have to explain it Turman
again Jamaica what's it all about
okay well
maker means a coalition of the Christian
Democrats bright wing conservatives the
as you put it business friendly Free
Democrats I'm not sure they're really
business friendly because business is
very we journalists have to tag them
with something well I call the Liberals
okay and the Green Party I think they're
all three of them fairly business
friendly but different aspects of
business but they're anyone so this is
the so-called Jamaica
black green yellow as the flag Jamaica
and this B's coalition this coalition
has just fallen apart right before even
starting before even we all thought it
was gonna happen
these were exploratory talks before real
tools a government could be formed that
would then be given the approval of the
the parties involved at some stage in
the very distant future yeah absolutely
but these talks went very much into
detail and I think they had like 200
sort of points to tick off and they you
know they got they've got incredibly far
they had agreed basically on the
question of immigration the greens were
ready to accept a level of upper limit
immigration where they had always said
never never no no no the the the the the
angle of macros party in the Bavarian
Christian socialist Union CSU the
Conservatives they were ready on the
other hand to have some kind of more
green policy closing down coal power
coal-fired power stations which the
Greens want and you know and everyone
really thought well the the Liberals
were sort of be in the middle and they
sort of slipped through but they decided
and this is the interesting thing they
decided at the last minute no we don't
want to govern and I don't think it's
not because they can't they don't want
to and the reason is I think they want
to go in the direction of a populist
National Democratic Party and take the
voters of the far-right AFD who got 13%
Germany anti-immigrant anti you and
there's been sort of Christian Lintner
the leader of the of the pro-business
free Democrat Party liberals
has been making sounds like this for
some weeks now and I think his idea is I
don't have to govern now I've got four
years time I've got eight years time I'm
a young guy I can build my party into
the right wing formation to the right of
Angela Merkel and the Christian
Democrats and then I can join government
with 20% of my belt in four years or in
eight years that's what he's aiming at
let's agree yes you know it's both true
they were not fit to govern or to rule
and at the same time he has this idea of
the becoming a nationals party I agree
with you completely but they would if
they had gone and became part of the
government they would have failed so
that's part of the truth but the main
question right now is the blame game who
is to blame
you know and it was not the last-minute
decision it was a decision that Lyndon
obviously took weeks ago
and then he tried to come out as the big
hero last night but every bit of
everybody can see it it didn't work that
way he he wanted to get out and he
wanted to make the statement I want to
make this point and he's trying to force
this government into new elections well
it's just we're talking about Christian
men let's just let's have a quick look
at what he had to say let's get a let's
get an impression gore give her a
viewers an impression of the man himself
because he has been widely viewed in
German politics in recent times as a man
of the future a charismatic political
politician Alan's nodding let's get a
flavor of the man himself we were being
forced to cast away our principles and
everything that we've fought for over
the years we will not let down our
voters by standing behind policies of
which we're not at all convinced it's
better not to govern than to govern
badly
Ulrika tell us a little bit more about
about the man himself about he is viewed
very often as one of the most capable
politicians in German politics is this a
long-term strategy that he has been
involved with here engaged in well yes
he was a part of the Liberal Party for
quite a long time since he was 20 or
something like that and whatever you
know even even much younger so from a
very early age onwards he was a
full-time politician for this Liberal
Party and what he saw in 2013 was how
his Liberal Party was thrown out of
Parliament because they had failed in
government together with Angela Merkel
they was dead and buried and he was the
one who managed all on earth by himself
as a one-man show the resurrection of
the Liberals and of course he the whole
part is traumatized they hardly any of
them really wants to rule again with
Angela Mecca because then they fear that
they would again be thrown out of
Parliament but I'd like to say something
about the strategy that Ellen somehow
sketched for the Liberals I think it
will not work if you have now new
elections I think that it is true that
the Liberals could get some of the votes
from the far-right but on the other hand
many of their traditional voters who
voted for them now again will leave for
the Christian Democrats because for them
it's no longer attractive to vote for
the Liberals now that the Liberals have
shown that they are no longer ready to
govern on to be part of a cabinet so
they will go to Angela Merkel so in the
in the end you know that's what I think
Lintner will not have more votes but he
will have a different basis more to the
right I agree totally with your
characterization of Linton and he is I
mean he is an incredibly charismatic guy
with him these events well I have a
couple of time in in in in you know in
in smaller groups and so on and he's
just so different from the
run-of-the-mill
liberal you know
he's really quite fascinating and you
need the kind of person you invite for
dinner and have a really good time with
I wouldn't want him to run the country
but will he lose votes no because the
people who voted for the mostly the
traditional free Democrat voted once
lower taxes that's basically everything
else they don't care about as long as
tax Sisco down and he's promising that
and none of the other parties want to
lower taxes so they'll go with that and
then on the other hand with his with his
Euroskeptic stance and with his
skeptical scant stance towards the
greens and towards more green energy and
so on hue and and and towards
immigration he will get a big slice of
the of the far-right vote so he it could
it could pay off for him it's all
interesting stuff Venna yeah but the
much more interesting question is where
were the CEO will go what will happen to
them you know well the voters still
support Angela Merkel and where will the
city you will end up in fresh elections
that is the crucial question today not
where the FDP is going just listen to
what angular miracle had to say after
the collapse of the coalition talks here
we go Angela Merkel German Chancellor
yeah uhm debye we've seen and heard a
lot during these talks there were very
different styles of negotiating Owens
fighting in all sympathy the Greens took
some getting used to the Free Democrats
were resolute
but we believed that we were on the
right path to securing an agreement -
Quinn
Mangala Merkel they're accused of being
pale and passive in the negotiations not
by everybody there were some
conservatives who said she had played a
very strong role as a behind-the-scenes
moderator where does she stand now what
is her future yeah even the Green Party
said that Angela Merkel had been a good
moderator of these talks so it's only
the Liberals who now pulled out who try
to blame angular market but it's not
what happened it's just to play a game
of blaming the other well what will
happen to angular Mecca I'm very
optimistic because if there was where
new elections which is not yet sure but
everyone counts on them I think very
many Germans will vote for Angela Merkel
and she will gain votes from almost all
parties for example many people who
voted for the Social Democrats will vote
for Macker next time because the Social
Democrats refused to go into a big
coalition and want to stay in opposition
but why should I vote for Social
Democrats who want to stay in a position
that makes no sense if I want to keep
angular maca in power the same I it's
something we disagree
me and Alan I think that quite a few
liberals will leave Christine Lintner
because it's true they all wanted to
have tax reductions but how are you
supposed to reduce the taxes when you're
in opposition it just doesn't work
so if those those who are somehow
rational voters for the Liberal Party
will now say well it's better to vote
for Macan who is in power and to
strengthen her in some coalition whoever
that will be instead of voting for Linda
so it shouldn't in the end the Christian
Democrats will have more votes than they
had now the premise here is that there
could very well be fresh elections that
is certainly a possible scenario at this
point in time however the German part of
the German president the federal
president Frank voter Steinmeier
has come out we all know and said that
the parties that this isn't a collapse
of the talks this is a breakdown of the
talks that the party should go back to
each other get back around the table and
talk yeah we'll have to see what key in
the end will actually say because here
he is the man who is in control of the
process and he has to decide what will
be next when it comes to fresh election
but on Angela Merkel's future I fully
agree but for different reasons she will
be there because there is no alternative
a lot of people in you live in this
country for a long long long time and
you know domestic politics and then
please do answer else oh you are young
people and other people even in this
country would very much like new faces
in politics but is the alternative
nobody can answer this really and as
long as we do not have this new face
then Angela Merkel will stay as simple
as that
is it gonna happen now they're gonna be
fresh elections well today is the day of
uncertainty we cannot predict this I'm
absolutely sure the Democrats said today
they and the devil did they confirmed
they will not go into a grand coalition
okay so that's off the table wait and
they want new elections that's what they
said today what they will say tomorrow
or in a week from now would then have to
push out Martin Schultz again as their
leader - but but but but the Social
Democrats they do have other faces it
could be under a annales with the
opposition leader now it could be the
mayor of Hamburg Schultz mr. Schultz so
they have alternatives and - for the
time being at least the Christian
Democrats do not have a viable option
what are you thinking yeah I'm thinking
it is boring but I'm thinking the same I
[Laughter]
do think we need fresh elect
because I mean if if the president
frank-walter Steinmeier if he said you
know this is not a collapse this is a
breakdown
that's that semantics I don't see the
difference between collapse and a break
that's me
interpreting what's the federal
president okay but I just just yesterday
or the day before on Sunday he told our
newspaper about Amazon tag that the code
that the Jamaica coalition's would
finally get their act together and and
and and finish their talks and conclude
them successfully no one listened to him
so why should they listen to him now
when mr. Lindner has left the coalition
so you know he can't go back he can't go
back and say oh I was wrong I'm very
sorry I'm gonna go big and and he
certainly can't go back and say well
okay I've thrown a temper tantrum now
take me in but I want to get this debt
and the other gals will say look you
left you know surely we're all good if
there if there are fresh elections we're
all going to have to come back to this
Jamaica scenario because there are there
is going to be six parties in the
Bundestag that's more than in the past
well you are more than likely going to
need or there's a real probability going
to need four of them to form a coalition
that's the situation we're already in so
you're going to be in the same situation
as you were before but with less trust
well firstly we don't know that it's
quite possible the Social Democrats if
they get rid of mr. Schultz as their
leader and that they could that they
actually do gain votes because voters
aren't rational if they were rational
they would do as you said but they but
they aren't so they might see themselves
in position to form a three-way
coalition with the ex communist
left-wing party with the Greens that was
that's always been on the table as a
possibility they don't have a majority
with it you don't know what's gonna
happen after the next election they
there could be I mean if if Chris and
lint that comes back with you know 12 13
14 % he could start dictating terms and
come quite a different position
you know there's throw everything up in
the air and see what happens and I think
that's the only only way out well I
think that many now due to this very
long period of debating it
maika coalition with greens and surf and
christian democrats and liberals I think
many Germans are now somehow adapted to
the idea that there might be a coalition
of the Green Party and the Christian
Democrats and I think that very many
people in now after this long talk about
Jamaica feel quite comfortable with this
idea and it could be that if there was a
new election people actively voted for
as we call it black green you have to
understand it's quite simple a lot of
people around Angela Merkel are it's
almost in the DNA that they want a black
green coalition for many many years
exactly even within the CSU you have
that try Germans like to call the
natural next government yeah that could
very well happen so what the worst thing
that could happen would be a minority
government that would be extremely bad
for Germany it would be extremely bad
for Europe and for the rest of the world
because a minority government would per
definition a government of uncertainty
and this isn't what Europe cannot stand
right now and therefore that would be
the worst thing that that could happen
and I'm British it will not happen
there's a real danger that we're going
to leave Monsieur McComb out in the cold
he's young and he said we want to lead
Europe with Germany in the tandem that
were so familiar to us until recent
times he wants to take Europe into a
stronger and more ambitious future in
Germany he's saying oh well we are
trying to form a government in hell I
mean he came out even last night with
that kind of a statement he called
Angela Merkel that's what we hear even
last night or during the night actually
later in the morning actually and to
make sure that she will not form a
minority government because that would
be very bad for France for her his
ambitions
concerning Europe and this as I said
that would be the worst scenario that
could happen and I don't think it will
happen I mean where champagne corks must
be popping all morning is in Moscow of
course because the one thing that Moscow
ones is to have Europe divided and
incapable of acting and this is exactly
what we have we were having BRICS it
talks they're on hold now as long as
Germany doesn't have a have a government
we've got this terrible division within
Europe between east and west between the
Visigoths states of Eastern Europe who
are anti-immigration anti neoliberalism
and basically anti any sort of
liberalism and with the Western European
states we've got all these things that
need resolving and there and and there
there's no leadership from Germany and
no leadership for maybe four or five
months so this is I mean what he must be
saying must be how could I be so lucky I
get Trump in America now I've got no
government in Germany Britain is
basically a government on hold it's all
going according supplies perhaps you
know Europe is trying to find itself but
I put in doesn't have any advantage from
that in Union is in disarray yeah but I
mean that's but yeah it that might be I
don't really agree but anyway that
doesn't help him all you can say is
Europe isn't disarray he can pursue his
destabilization program in Ukraine for
instance which make no mistake about it
is designed to reintegrate Europe the
Empire and there's no angle America has
been the person who stopped him from
doing that but you know I think that
whatever result the German elections
would have had or could have had you
know this Ukraine problem would never
have been it attacked anyway by the
Europeans you know they are already
resigned to the idea that it will go to
Russia we're running out of time I'm
afraid so I'd like to ask ask each of
you to tell me what the best case
scenario is from this point in time
dennah and
I think fresh elections are unavoidable
and the outcome that you would view as
the best case scenario then and my gut
feeling tells me it will be a black
green coalition yes my gut feeling I
must say I didn't come into the show
feeling that that was Germany's future
maybe I'm beginning to be convinced by
the prospect Allen I also think that we
need fresh elections and I would
actually quite welcome it if the Free
Democrats could again a whole lot more
votes and then from black yellow
coalition centre-right coalition thus
leaving a strong center left opposition
of the greens and the Reds well you
might call back to the future yeah a
little bit well I hope not back because
that was cut at the last black yellow
coalition was a catastrophe but Linton
is a different prospect he could he
could swing it well if this is an option
but then we would have a racist and
government because as you said Lintner
wants to become very nationalistic
racist or even racist so I I do not
think that a yellow black government was
a Lintner who has turned nationalistic
would be a very nice option I don't
think we can conclude this show by
calling a linear racist too far nobody
wants to okay it's a bit far but he
wants to pick the those who vote for AFD
and many of them are racists have to
leave it there on a note of controversy
thank you very much for joining us the
special edition of quadriga talking
about the collapse of German coalition
talks let's see what comes next
bye-bye just
[Music]
you